[Music]
hey everybody it's Charlie Marvel just
made a couple big reveals about what's
happening with Avengers 4 Scarlet Witch
envision their spin-off TV series that's
coming to the Disney streaming service
and finally revealed who Jude Law is
playing during the Captain Marvel movie
it's a really big twist
so we'll do new round of that IMAX take
a giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a Marvel
related comment on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this starting
with the Scarlet Witch and vision stuff
then I'll talk about Captain Marvel so
if you guys didn't know what's going on
the Disney streaming service is getting
a whole bunch of Avengers spin-off TV
series after Avengers 4 it'll be the
Avengers MCU actors reprising their
roles for different types of stories so
even though a bunch of them are going to
get made not all of them will take place
after the events of Avengers 4 the Loki
TV series they announced is probably
going to be a prequel because they don't
want to undercut his death during
infinity war but I think we can all
assume the Scarlet Witch and vision are
probably gonna come back during Avengers
4 their series will take place after and
would just be a continuation of the
ongoing story that they've had in the
background since Civil War like there
was a lot of stuff going on during
Infinity Ward they tried to give them
their own little sub story about their
relationship and what it meant that she
had to sacrifice vision in order to save
the universe and how it still didn't
work Tannis was still able to use the
time stone to rewind things and take the
mine stone from vision they officially
revealed that the title though is a bit
of a reversal we've been referring to it
as the Scarlet Witch in vision series
because first they announced Scarlet
Witch and then a little while later
they're like oh by the way vision is
also gonna be in the series too now
deadline is reporting that the official
title Marvel has given the series is
vision and Scarlet Witch so vision gets
top billing longtime comic book fans
will recognize that that was the title
of their first solo comic series
together it only ran for two volumes in
the early and mid 80s and it mostly
focused on their relationship but there
were a couple big things that they did
during that the biggest twist of the
first volume was mostly retconning her
back stories so that magneto was her and
quicksilver's father before the mid 80s
he was and even though they had been
hinting at that in later x-men titles
around that time but since the character
was created her backstory has changed a
lot so during that run magneto becomes
her father he vows to end
wicked ways I'm gonna be a good person
now I'm not gonna be a villain anymore
then the big twist of the second volume
is what most people remember when they
think of a Scarlet Witch envisions
relationship that's the volume where she
and vision have twin babies remember
twins run in the family but that was
really all they did there was no huge
villain it was all about family drama
and the funny thing that happened after
that run is that the Marvel editorial
team hated what Steve Englehart did with
that he was the writer that did those
babies during the storyline Marvel
editorial absolutely hated that they
read Condit later during West Coast
Avengers 51 and 52 that's where they
revealed that her twins had not been
real they were just fragments of
Mephisto soul so obviously was a really
big twist but really it was Marvel's way
of retconning that so in present
continuity she never had any mystery
children with vision the TV series just
like the comic though will be them
trying to reconcile their powers their
relationship in the way the rest of the
world perceives them by the time they
start working on the series they'll have
already gotten all the x-men characters
outside chance they try to canonize her
as a mutant officially during the series
but Marvel has already kind of given her
a lot of x-men themed stories within the
MCU between what happened to sokovia in
Captain America Civil War with the
accident and all the public hating her
because of what she did no one dislikes
you wonder thanks oh you're welcome
no it's a involuntary response in their
amygdala they can't help but be afraid
of you are you i amygdala is synthetics
I used to think of myself one way but
after this I am something else
I'm still me I think that's not what
everyone else sees the whole idea of
their characters are is that they're so
powerful and nobody really understands
them fully so they're just kind of weary
about them so the series will just be a
continuation of that and I think a lot
of how crazy they go into comic book
stuff just depends on how many seasons
her series runs for if it goes for
multiple seasons then we can start
talking about Magneto other x-men stuff
maybe having more Quicksilver
appearances if they want to do
flashbacks because unless they change
something during adventures 4 he'll
still be dead when this series picks up
but like with any TV series you have all
that extra time you can do mental
flashbacks she can remember Quicksilver
so there are ways to include him in the
TV series without him being alive in
present-day
they haven't revealed who the villains
going to be or any other big plot
details outside of what I just mentioned
so we'll probably hear a little bit more
about that early next year as they're
ramping up for Avengers 4 I would expect
them to wait to start promoting those
series till after they get done with
that but Captain Marvel this is big news
they finally revealed the Jude Law is
playing on Rob not the original Captain
Marvel from the comics and now the plot
makes a lot more sense Yuri watch that
trailer and she's talks about lost
memories not knowing where she came from
I'm not who you think I am it all makes
a lot more sense when the villain is
pretending to be one of the heroes we
also found out that Carol Danvers Kree
name is going to be verse I don't know
how they're gonna pronounce this but
it's basically Danvers with the Dan cut
off so her learning about her human name
will probably play into her discovering
the truth that jaan raghav her this
whole time so Yuri watched the trailer
in a more linear fashion and it goes
down like this
regular Air Force pilot Carol Danvers
gets into an accident while
investigating jaan raghav in Earth's
orbit they crash land and get into a
fight during that fight the psychie
magnetron explodes giving Carol Danvers
her powers or unlocking her powers but
it also knocks her out cold and by the
time she's woken up jaan raghav her
pre-existing memories and lied to her
about who she really is he tells her her
name is vers maybe they picked that name
because part of her name tag on her
jacket gets burned off so that may be
the funny inspiration for the verse name
but because she doesn't have any
memories yon brothels her with false
memories tells her that she's a member
of the Kree Empire she has a
responsibility to serve them in Star
Force because she has special powers the
Korean the Skrulls are in the middle of
this longtime ongoing war so she just
buys it and becomes a member of the team
and starts taking out Scrolls one at a
time so part of the movie is them
defeating the scrolls like you see
during the trailer Talos is their leader
played by Ben Mendelsohn he's definitely
a bad person but also part of the movie
as Carol Danvers realizing that Yann
Rock has been lying to her this whole
time
reclaiming her identity and her true
potential for power we have our fingers
crossed for a binary reveal but notice
how early in the trailer she seems less
powerful when she's wearing the green
crease star force uniform she's giving
off blasts but she doesn't look nearly
as powerful as she does when she's in
her comic book Captain Marvel costume at
the end of the trailer so if you're not
familiar with Yann Drago the psyche
magnatron the psyche magnetron is just
something that jaan raghav people powers
so that's its only function in the
comics they might change that a little
bit for the movie but you can see how he
wants to win the war against the scrolls
and Captain Marvel represents this
really big opportunity for him like oh
wow this super powerful person that I
can trick into believing that she's a
member of the Kree and use her to take
down our hated enemies what I'm
expecting though is that we'll get a
little bit more of that in the trailers
obviously more of young Coulson and
young Nick Fury they'll have some fun
with that but here's the thing about all
this though they have made no mention of
what they've done with the original
version of Captain Marvel if he's even a
character in the MCU if they're just
omitting him entirely so let me know in
the comments what do you think about
this jaan raghav ah twist it makes a lot
of sense based on the way they pitched
the movie I mean it's all about false
memories discovering the people have
been lying to you but when we get more
footage I'll start to do more breakdown
videos leave your requests in the
comments below
congratulations crit Robbins you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to learn why Marvel and
Netflix just cancelled daredevil and
click here for that big Avengers for
infinity war event all the reveals and
the plot teasers thank you so much for
watching
ever
if they awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]